[Music]
tonight
because
you've been talking love and dating and
now we're getting into dream date
scenarios as well as steeped in reality
so
um what else are you looking for well
now listen I've dated some of the most
powerful some of the most wealthy some
of the I know there's some great
athletes uh that was that fun yes it was
yes it was when you walk in the stadium
and everybody's cheering for your date
it's a great feeling but I can also date
I've dated cops I've dated firemen I've
which is a lot of fun man them firemen
yeah baby yeah baby throw that hose over
his shoulders
oh I mean there's a reason like they're
so hot there are calendars built in
their honors action workers yeah yeah
yes waiters yes see this is what I love
yeah I mean that's it that's real world
that's real life you know and you were
in like the military yes you know
military men
[Applause]
Pilots you know anybody well uniforms I
love uniforms so that always works well
with Drew I don't want sex on the first
day even though I've you know been
caught slipping and it happened but I
don't really want to do it
because I wouldn't either but I know why
for me why why for you well you know I'm
I'm a good kisser hey Usher I'm a good
kisser and I like the kiss but but I'm
at an age now where I just don't want to
do that I want romance right I Want From
Here to Eternity wins the race yes yes
and yes and I don't want to give up my
body first and then you got to find the
matching bra and panty set and get ready
for all of that and lotion stuffing guys
I don't want to do all that I want I
want to kiss good night and and go home
and go to bed in my own do I need to get
matching bra and panties oh yeah when
the first the first time you do it you
gotta had a matching bra and panty set
on I guess I need a big white cotton
Broad
especially if that guy gets him hot out
the dryer and hands them to you
some hot panties out the dryer that's
love that's love oh my God I literally
cook my kids clothes in the dryer and
then I hand them to them and I go toast
yes yes yes
so yeah it's so funny I'm so good at
love yes but for everybody else be good
at love for yourself well help me get
there Cheryl and we'll help each other
together that's what I want to do and
and see each other's Cupid that's right
I love it wingman yeah wing women
exactly yes
[Music]
[Applause]
our beautiful show that we love so much
that we feel so Akin and family too airs
weekdays at two Eastern one Pacific on
CBS and it's available to stream live
and On Demand always on Paramount plus
and up next we have a tip that works out
your mind and your bod
I feel like this segment did the same
but we'll be right back with more
thank you
[Music]